episode four on the podcast back with
Julie Pyatt
so what did we talk about today there's
a little trailer video we're gonna tell
you a little bit about what to expect in
this fourth episode of the podcast we
talked about crashing rich crash today
he's got a little road rash I crushed my
bike today out here in Kauai so we
talked a little bit about cycling in
Kauai which kind of brought us into
talking about my ultraman race in 2009
cuz I crashed in that and kind of go
through that story a little bit and then
we take a hard left we start talking
about relationships and how we kind of
try to make it work and some of the
pitfalls that we've had and how we kind
of navigated this journey together and
Julie pontificates beautifully with some
really amazing relationship advice Oh
possibly
yeah yeah yeah so and then Julie and
Tyler take us out with a beautiful live
version of Julie song in the Sun so
stick around all the way to the end it's
worth it you want to check out the
podcast you can find it on itunes the
rich roll podcast you go to rich we're
all calm and listen to it there we're
also on stitcher radio thank you for
your support as of today we were the
number 22 podcast on iTunes for like all
podcasts that includes like the Adam
Carolla Show and This American Life and
Alec Baldwin's podcast and all this
stuff so it's amazing that you know
we're only a week into this and that
we're in that same you know community of
amazing broadcasters and amazing talent
and why because of you guys because of
your support thank you thank you so much
for your support we're gonna do our best
to bring you some really great content
so
you all join us for the journey and we
hope you enjoy this episode
you